اعلن البيت الابيض معارضه اداره بايدن
الشديده لتمرير مجلس النواب مشروع قانون
جمهوري يقضي بتخصيص ينص على مساعدات
تكمليه طارئه لاسرائيل حيث يستثني القرار
الملفات الاخرى ضمن حزمه الامن القومي
وذكر بيان لمكتب الميزانيه في البيت
الابيض ان الاداره امضت شهورا في العمل مع
مجلس الشيوخ للتوصل الى اتفاقيه توفر
الدعم لكل من الاونر واسرائيل ولامن
الحدود وغيرها من الملفات كما قال ان امن
اسرائيل الذي يعتبر مقدسا لا يجوز ان
يستخدم لعبه سياسيه مقابل تجاهل مساعده
الشعب الاوكراني وتقديم المساعدات
للمدنيين الفلسطينيين ودعى البيان
الكونغرس الى رفض ما سماها الحيله
السياسيه وتمرير قانون المخصصات التكميليه
الذي تم الاتفاق عليه اكد البيت الابيض ان
الرئيس بايدن سيستخدم حق الفيتو اذا ما تم
اعتماد هذا القرار في
المجلسين